Das ist die Podcast Pufo, Hymne, mit Stefan Tietzes, angenehmer Stimme. Erst war er schüchtern, dann fing er Stand-up an und wird seitdem leider etwas arrogant. Florentin Wills Humor hat nur einer, war als steht ihm besser, doch im Podcast sieht das eh keiner. The Change Wir müssen ein bisschen leiser reden, leider, bei dieser... Wir sind wieder in einem sehr halligen Raum, aber... Ich glaube, es heilt einfach nur leiser dann, wenn man leiser spricht. Vielen Dank an das Intro. An MC Schmid. Ich finde das ein angenehmer Ansatz, auch mal in dem Intro so ein bisschen auf die negativen Seiten der Protagonisten zuzugreifen. Ich weiß nicht, dass ich arrogant werde, etwas im Intro zu tun hat. Also ich finde es gut, dass ich Feedback bekomme. Ich weiß nicht, ob es in unserem Intro sein muss. Ich finde, das sollte man durchsetzen. Gummibären, tapfer, stark, nehm es mit der Wahrheit, aber nicht ganz so genau. Es gab auch schon mal bessere Folgen, das geben wir zu. Es ist eine schöne Zeit, Stefan. Wir befinden uns hier am letzten Vorweihnachtsfolge. Wir sind in der KW 51, das kann man auch mal sagen, 51 von 52, das sind die eine von vier Wochen, wo ich die Kalenderwoche nennen kann, weil man grob weiß, wo man ist. Aber wenn man mitten des Jahres irgendwie um die Ecke kommt mit, wann kannst du, KW 19 oder 20, schreie ich immer, bin immer viel zu aufgeladen direkt und sage immer, kannst du mich einfach, kannst du mich mal am Arsch lecken mit deinem Scheiß. Ich glaube, es gibt auch drei verschiedene Arten von Menschen, die, die in KWs denken, die, die in Monaten denken und die, die in Tageszeiten denken. Wir haben Leute, die manchmal wissen, okay, es ist 14 Uhr, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ich bin, keine Ahnung, wie ich heiße, aber es ist 14 Uhr. Ja, Dienstag ist auch, Wochentage sind ja auch ein bisschen überholt und egal. Mit welcher Prozentsatz kannst du das aktuelle Datum wiedergeben?
Wenn ich dich an irgendeinen Random-Tag frage, wie ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du den konkreten Datum nennen kannst? Zehn Prozent. Zehn Prozent? Ja. Glaubst du, irgendwas Positives oder Menschenbewegendes ist mal in der KW 51 noch passiert? Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das meiste wird ja auch ignoriert, die Medien haben abgeschaltet. In dem Moment, wo man sagt, man teilt etwas eine Zeit ein in Jahre oder Monate, minimiert man nicht sofort die Tage, an denen besondere Dinge entstehen, weil niemand am ersten ist erstmal so, ach, jetzt hat der Monat gerade erst angefangen, so, jetzt habe ich den ganzen August noch vor mir, irgendwas Bewegendes zu leisten, meine Relativitätstheorie aufzustellen, zu falsifizieren, whatever. Am Ende des Monats ist es auch keiner mehr, jetzt mache ich nächsten Monat in Ruhe, dieses typische, das mache ich morgen früh in Ruhe. Das hat man ja genauso auch im Monat, das hat man auch genauso in einem Jahr, das mache ich nächstes Jahr. Aber ist es nicht so, glaubst du die Menschheit wäre weiter, wenn es so etwas wie Jahre, Tage nicht gäbe? Ich glaube, man ist diesen Schritt schon gegangen. Soweit ich weiß, war das Jahr ja ursprünglich nur vier Tage lang. Und von diesen vier Tagen konnte man an zwei nicht arbeiten, weil man gesagt hat, heute ist der erste Tag des Jahres, lass uns mal in Ruhe. Und heute ist der letzte Tag des Jahres, lass uns das nächste Jahr machen. Silvester, erst mal Silvester Vorbereitung. Somit waren 50 Prozent aller Tage, und der eine war noch am Feiertag, das heißt, du hast eigentlich nur an einem Tag im Jahr arbeiten können. Und da ist natürlich alles liegen geblieben. Irgendwie so eine Burg baut sich dann halt erstmal in 500 Jahren auf, wenn du halt alle vier Tage Pause nur einen Stein riecht. In Richtung Sommer war dann immer so, jedes Jahr wird es wärmer. Klingt dir das gerade? Es wird jedes Jahr wärmer. Hitzefrei ständig. Es ist unglaublich, jedes Jahr wird es wärmer, das ganze Jahr war hitzefrei. Ja, nee, es ist nervig. Nee, ich finde das schon okay. Aber auch mal einen kleinen Shoutout an alle, die zur Weihnachtszeit Geburtstag haben, als Kind immer total nervig, weil man nur einen Geschenk bekommt. Ich glaube, im Erwachsenenalter wird das immer angenehmer, weil die Leute sich überhaupt noch an deinen Geburtstag erinnern, weil du dann halt zu Weihnachten zumindest ein doppeltes Weihnachtsgeschenk bekommst. Es sind überproposional viele Leute meines Erachtens, die einen Silvestergeburtstag haben. Echt? Silvester und Neujahr kenne ich 15 Leute bestimmt. Wahnsinn. Und ich kenne nur 16. Heißt also wirklich sehr viele Leute haben um dieses Datum herum Geburtstag. Und an die Geburtstage denke ich immer. Jedes Jahr schreibe ich, auch wenn ich nicht wirklich doll mit dem befreundet bin, schreibe ich den besagten Leuten, ihr wisst genau, wenn ich meine. Draußen, ihr wisst es schon, wir kennen uns nicht gut, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr einen zweiten Vornamen habt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Geschwister habt, aber ich krieg jedes Jahr von mir eine nette Geburtstags-Whatsapp, einfach weil ich mir das Datum gut merken kann, weil es Silvester ist. War es ein schönes Jahr für dich? War es der Ereignisreich? Der Ereignisreich ist ein langes Jahr, nee, es kam mir tatsächlich sehr kurz vor, hinten raus speziell viel erlebt. Ich bin ein Stück weit ein neuer Mensch geworden, habe mich neu erfunden. Du bist ein bisschen arrogant geworden. Ihr seid arrogant geworden, das Intro hat mir das auch nahegelegt, aber die Message ist angekommen, nächstes Jahr wird wieder das sympathischere Jahr. Aber man muss ja manchmal auch ein bisschen abheben, um dann zu wissen, dass man auch mal auf dem Boden stand. Ist völlig richtig. Absolut. Oder nicht. Absolut. Ich finde, Sprichwörter haben in jeglichen Sinn verloren für mich. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was das Sprichwort war, aber Zitat war das. Als ich am Bahnhof in Stuttgart ankam für unsere Liveshow, hing ein großes Zitat von Goethe, aber so ein ganz, ganz generisches Kackzitat, wo ich wirklich dachte, oh Wolfgang. Aber ist es ja tatsächlich so, dass viele große Leute auch ziemlich viel Scheiss gesagt haben, aber oft halt nur so das Beste rausgenommen wird. Man müsste eigentlich mal so ein The Worst Of Goethe schreiben. Es gibt ja viele Best Ofs, so dann Best Of Nietzsche, so die geilsten One-Liner, die coolsten Burns, so die krassesten Snacks oder so und dann einfach so The Worst Of, einfach so den grössten Bullshit, den Goethe geschrieben hat, einfach so ein, eigentlich, ich meine so ein bisschen wie die Karriere von Da Vinci, einfach mal so ein The Worst Of, einfach so, wo wirklich nichts funktioniert. Wobei man muss sagen, Da Vinci kommt sehr schlecht bei uns weg, aber wer viel zu gut wegkam, noch bislang ist Aristoteles. Ja, Alter. Auch ein grauenhafter Vollidiot. Aristoteles, sag ich ja häufiger. Ja, sagst du häufig. Und ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, jedes Mal denke ich mir, wir müssen uns einen besseren Schimpfnamen ausdenken, aber so lange sagt er das noch. Wie lief die Beerdigung von Aristoteles eigentlich ab? Gab es da einen Liedermacher, der sein ganzes Leben lang drauf gewartet hat? Erst wäre er am Leben, jetzt ist Aristoteles. Ist das nicht ein viel zu happy Song für eine Beerdigung? Nee, wir sind ja antikes Griechenland, da ist die emotionale Verbindung noch anders. Ach so. Also für uns ist es ... Traurig. Super traurig. Sehr lustig. Lass uns tanzen. Oh, es hat mir unser freundlicher Cutter, der der Serie für dich arbeite, erzählt, dass man indogenen Völkern
Musik vorgespielt hat.
Und zwar einmal Schubert,
irgendeine Symphonie,
und einmal die Musik von Jaws.
Bei einem haben sie sich kaputt gelacht,
bei dem anderen sind sie geflohen
in die Büsche zurück.
Jetzt sagst du mir mal, was was ist. Ja, natürlich. Ich würde jetzt sagen, sie haben sich kaputt gelacht bei Jaws und vor Schubert sind sie geflohen. Es war genau umgekehrt, ich habe mich kaputt gelacht über Schubert, bin ich kaputt gelacht, also es wäre zum Musikalischer Witz. Auch so gut weggekommen, ehrlich gesagt, bei uns. Also Schubert muss man auch mal sagen, was für ein Volldepp. Also wirklich. Für mich ist es wie ein Comedian. Von der ersten bis zur letzten Sinfonie nur Bock, Mist, Geschwatsch, nur Lust, nur Rotz. Ja, das sagt das indogene Folge, dachte das auch. Wohingegen Jaws hat den Angst eingejagt. Echt? Ja, das ist schon beeindruckend. Also da kann sich John Williams schon mal auf die Schütter klopfen, dass er armen, indogenen Menschen Angst eingehakt hat.
Ich finde das cool, weil es zeigt ja, das eine ist viel instinktiver, ist die viel instinktiver Musik, ist ja fast gar keine Musik, Jaws ist ja wahrscheinlich, das werden sie am Anfang vorgespielt haben, der vor allem sehr aus dem Bauch raus impulsiv, instinktiv, furchterregend ist, wo eher Geräusche ja auch sind, gruselige Geräusche, wohingegen das andere ja eigentlich auch Musik ist,
für die du Vorkenntnisse brauchst, eine gewisse Vorbildung, Einordnung brauchst etc. Finde ich schon spannend. Lass uns nochmal ganz kurz die diesjährige Jahr abschliessen mit einer Folge aus unserer fantastischen Kategorie Dumm Vinci. Zwar habe ich eine Frage zum Thema Dumm Vinci, und zwar möchte ich von dir wissen, warum ist die Mona Lisa so berühmt? Das ist eine gute Frage. Ist ja ein bisschen gar nicht sinnbildlich fürs Werk, fürs Werk da Vinci's, dumm Vinci's, wischi waschi's. Warum ist gerade die Mona Lisa so berühmt? Ich weiß nicht, ihr Lächeln, der Fakt, dass der eine Horizont ein bisschen höher ist als der andere, auch Trottel, hat einfach kein Lineal genommen. Nein, Mona Lisa wurde mal gestohlen. Mona Lisa wurde gestohlen, das Gemälde wurde gestohlen, war lange verschollen, ganz Frankreich oder wo auch immer das war, hat nach ihr gesucht, überall und irgendwann ist es dann auch wieder aufgetaucht und danach war es berühmt. Und warum wurde gerade Mona Lisa gestohlen? Ist das ein Quiz oder was? Ist das denn für ein Kreuzverhör? Was ist das für ein Kreuzverhör? Warum wurde... Wo hast du denn gestern zwischen 18 und 19 Uhr? Warum hat der Dieb gerade Mona Lisa gestohlen, das Gemälde Mona Lisa? Ich glaube, weil es gut in Sonne Küche gepasst hat. Weil es klein ist. Nein, doch. Das heißt, Dumm Vincchi ist bekannt, weil er klein gemalt hat? Exakt. Rückführend der einzige Grund, warum die Mona Lisa das bekannteste Gemälde der Welt ist, ist, weil es ein relativ kleines, handliches, gut zu klauenes Bild ist, gut wegsnackbares Bild ist, das man als Dieb leicht klauen kann. Und dadurch wurde es so berühmt und dadurch wurde die Mona Lisa die Mona Lisa. Also auch hier Dumm Vinci weit weg von dem Genie, einfach nur ein sehr fauler Maler, der ein sehr kleines Bild gemalt hat. Das hat ihn zu Weltrufe. Jetzt wurde ja hier Deus Mundi, wie ist es, versteigert? Von Quincy ist dieses andere, nee, jedes Element dieser Story habe ich falsch gemacht.
Falsches Subjekt. Es wurde nicht geklaut, es wurde zurückgegeben.
Genau, es ist Verlagerung.
Nee, Christie's hat...
Quincy's?
Heißt sie jetzt Salvador Mundi?
King of Queens?
Salvador Mundi, also so ein Gemälde von Da Vinci wurde versteigert, mit Jesus drauf, ich glaube 350 Millionen oder so was, 400 Millionen, wahnsinnig teuer. Da habe ich zugeschaut bei der Versteigerung, ich liebe Versteigerungen, grossartig, vor allem, es ist ja immer so cool, weil die Versteigerungen, die tatsächlichen Leute, die bieten am Ende, die sind nicht persönlich da, sondern die telefonieren immer rein. Nee, die sind explizit nicht da. Genau, die sind einfach im Lebenraum. Ich denk es mir auch so, warum kommen die denn nicht? Wenn du so viel Geld hast, dass du für 350 Millionen ein Bild ersteigern kannst, warum bist du dann nicht da? Was hast du zu tun? Du bist bereit, 350 Millionen für ein Gemälde auszugeben, und dann willst du nicht mal dabei sein, wie Leute sehen, holy crap, der Typ hat so viel Geld, dass er sich für 350 Millionen so ein mittelmäßiges Dominci-Bild erstellen kann. Wegen welcher Aktion oder wegen welcher Verpflichtung ist er nicht da? Also was hat dieser Mensch noch zu tun? Also vor allem, da ist ja immer der Auktionator in der Mitte und dann gibt es diese ganzen Telefonleute links und die ganzen Telefonleute rechts.
Und auf den ersten Blick denkt man, die würden miteinander telefonieren. Aber nein, die telefonieren und dann sagt... Die kann, vor allem, wenn ich in einem Raum bin, wo jemand anderes noch telefoniert, kann ich schon nicht mehr telefonieren, weil ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren. Zum einen nicht auf das, was der gegenüber sagt, was ich sagen muss, ist meistens auch dann schon zu laut in dem Raum, ich verlasse den Raum. Die telefonieren mit hundert Menschen in dem Raum.
Der wahre Beweis, dass die reich sind, ist, dass sie sich leisten können, so ein langes Telefonat zu führen,
weil die müssen wahrscheinlich schon vor der Steigung losgeht am Apparat sein, oder?
Und dann ist immer, okay, wir bauen jetzt die Schüler auf.
Ich dachte, als Kind immer, die telefonieren alle mit ihrer Mutter.
Bitte, ach komm, nur vierhundert Millionen, bitte, für Geburtstag und Weihnachten zusammen. Eins noch mehr, eins, das ist schön blau. Aber wie früh gehen die ans Telefon? Sie stellen jetzt die Stühle auf, ernst ein, die trägt einen Anzug, hat jetzt Champagnergläser in der Hand. Ich glaube, ich ruf nochmal zurück gleich. Aber telefonieren ist doch 20% telefonieren, 80% hallo? Bist du noch da? Hallo? Bist du noch da? Ich hatte gerade so ein Knackgeräusch. Hallo? Jetzt geht es wieder, glaube ich. Hallo? Nee, du bist weg. Ich ruf nochmal an. Ja. Das ist doch 80 Prozent eines Telefonats. Deswegen verstehe ich nicht genau, wie das funktioniert. Und da fährt auch mal irgendwann ein Tunnel und sagt, was haben Sie gesagt? 500 Millionen? Wir sind erst bei zwei Euro. Zum Ersten zum Zweiten. Ich habe haben einen Tunnel. Wir haben einen 318er. Vor allem, was ich so lustig fand, was ich so extrem willkürlich fand, bei dieser Versteigerung, sind die Stufen, in denen versteigert wird. Ja, das habe ich auch nie verstanden. Weil da ging es dann so, 100 Millionen, 100 Millionen, 102, 102 Millionen, 102 Millionen, 200 Millionen, 200 Millionen, 230,zwei Millionen, zweihundert Millionen, zweihundert Millionen, zweihundert Millionen, zweihundert dreissig, zweihundert dreissig, zweihundert dreissig, zweihundert dreissig, zweihundert fünfzig. Es ist willkürlich, einfach willkürliche Stufen. Ja, vor allem, die halten ja auch nicht die Summen hoch, sondern die halten ja ihre Bieternummer hoch. Ja, auch zur Verwirrung. Aber woher kommt dann auch zur Verwirrung vieler? Aber wie kommt denn auf diese Summe, der Versteigerer? Es ist total merkwürdig, weil irgendwie, vor allem es ging dann irgendwie von 100 auf 200 Millionen hat es total lange gedauert und von 200 auf 400 dann ganz schnell irgendwie. Dann ging es natürlich super schnell. Wo ich mir denke, die haben sich davor irgendwie noch drei Bieter so 105, 106, nein 107, 108, 109 und am Ende sind es 400 Millionen und die denken sich auch, da haben wir uns ewig rumgesteigert, ob es jetzt 100 oder 110 Millionen sind einfach.
Aber es ist grossartig, es ist schon lustig, vor allem du denkst dir halt immer so, ich bin jetzt 300 Millionen drin, ob ich 300 oder 305 Millionen zahle, macht keinen Unterschied mehr. Aber irgendwann musst du bei diesen Fünfer-Schritten schon aufhören einfach, weil das ist so wie dieser Hummer im Kochtopf, wo es immer langsam wärmer wird, der irgendwann tot ist. Genauso wie es ist, du bist halt irgendwann pleite, du denkst halt immer nur fünf mehr, fünf mehr. Nee, ich habe 605 Millionen, das ist schon interessant. Ab welchem Punkt sagen Sie, hören Sie auf? Ist egal, ja, nee, auch an welchem Punkt ist das, ja, du hast ja irgendwann, jetzt hast du eine Schmerzgrenze, es ist halt dann keine Schmerzgrenze mehr. Aber wir kennen das alle, wir haben die Schmerzgrenze zu 200 Millionen. Und dann sagt er 203 Millionen, du sagst, ach komm, die drei Millionen, die klemmen bei mir zwischen Sofakissen. So, komm, kein Problem, 203. Die kriegst du ja nicht mal schnell aufgetrieben, ich weiß es nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist eine gute Frage. Mir wurde mal ein Bild geklaut. Ja, ich war mal in einer Bar, in einer wirklich fancy Bar, und dann war ich da mit einem Kumpel und da waren wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz tolle Bilder an den Wänden. Und dann habe ich gesagt, so ein schönes Bild, würde ich gerne bei mir hinhängen. Kannst du mir das klauen? So aus Spaß, habe ich gesagt. Dann war es lustig, man hat sich, man hat ein bisschen was getrunken, man hatte Spaß. Und dann beim Rausgehen habe ich dann so gesagt, das ist gar nicht geklaut. Und dann bin ich schon zum Taxi gegangen und plötzlich sehe ich nur, wie der Kumpel hinter mir einfach wieder zurück in den Laden rennt, das Bild von der Wand nimmt und ich habe nicht schnell geschaltet, bin dann ins Taxi gestiegen, habe gesagt, fahren Sie, fahren Sie, fahren Sie, der Kumpel ist reingerannt, ich habe die Tür noch aufgemacht, der ist dann ein bisschen ins fahrende Auto. Und dann hab ich gesagt, das kannst du doch nicht machen, das bin jetzt wieder zurück. Dann waren wir aber schon auch auf einer relativ befahrenen Hauptstraße, war halt eine grosse Stadt. Und dann hat er das Bild gehabt einfach. Unter seinem Pulli ist er aus dem Laden rausgerannt. Also auch ein kleines Bild. Ein kleines Bild, ja. Exakt, aber es ist ein kleines Bild. Und dann habe ich jetzt bei mir zu Hause rumliegen, weil mir dann unangenehm ist, das einfach zurückzugeben. Und dann behalte ich es lieber jetzt. Mittlerweile weiß ich auf sicherer Quelle, dass da mittlerweile wieder ein neues Bild hängt. Einfach an andere. Wurde sehr schnell ersetzt. Das ist wie so ein Jahreskalender, wo die einfach so eine Seite wegreißen und drunter ist das nächste Bild. Und das habe ich jetzt noch bei mir zu Hause. Und das wurde mir einfach geklaut. Und dann waren wir auf dem dem Nachhauseweg, habe ich die ganze Zeit darüber nachgedacht, weil wir haben darüber geredet, wie kann ich dem Taxifahrer jetzt die Gewalt über uns entziehen, weil der hat mitbekommen gerade, dass wir eine Strafe begangen haben. Und dann habe ich gesagt, weil er als, da habe ich ihn erst nach Hause fahren lassen, uns, und dann habe ich gesagt so, da Sie nichts gemacht haben bislang, sind Sie ja unser Fluchtwagenfahrer.
Sie kommen ja mit Sicherheit auch in den Knast, wenn wir in den Knast kommen. Und dann war er ein bisschen unter Druck und hat dann gedacht, okay, dann sage ich nichts. Jetzt ist irgendwo ein Taxifahrer in Berlin, der jede Nacht nicht schlafen kann. Der hat dein Gesicht, der denkt, du bist von einer Mafia irgendwie sowas. Oder ich mache das täglich.
Genau, ich glaube täglich Bilder.
Aber da kann man natürlich diskutieren, ob du, wenn du mit Diebesgut in einem Taxi fließt, ob der Taxifahrer schuldig ist?
Ich glaube nicht.
Der weiss ja nicht, dass er Teil von einem... Doch, doch, das haben wir ja hinten lauthals, teils dem Alkohol geschuldet, laut diskutiert.
Aber er kann ja behaupten, dass er es nicht wusste.
Gerne sagen, die haben das nicht gesagt. Aber welcher Rechtsgrundlage ist, diskutieren wir denn jetzt? Jeder kann ja irgendwie behaupten. Ich kann ja auch behaupten, dass er es nicht wusste. Er kann ja sagen, die haben das nicht gesagt.
Aber wenn er auch Rechtsklage sagt, diskutieren wir denn jetzt. Jeder kann ja irgendwie behaupten.
Ich kann ja auch behaupten, ich hätte ihn nicht umgebracht.
Ja gut, aber wenn es jetzt ein Kumpel von dir gewesen wäre, der davor wartet, dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass ihr Komplizen seid.
Dass er ein Kumpel davon wusste, der den Fluchtwagen fährt.
Aber wenn es ein Taxifahrer ist, was weisst du, was der für einen Scheiss jeden Tag hört?
Der hört doch irgendwann nicht mehr zu, was die Leute da für einen Schwachsinn erzählen. Aber das weiss man nicht genau.
Ich habe viele Freunde, die auch sagen, das Beste ist immer mit Taxifahrten, um auch die peinliche Stille zu überwinden, ist immer nach der krassesten Geschichte zu fragen, die dieser Taxifahrer mal erlebt hat. Mein Ziel war es, auch mal irgendwann diese Geschichte zu sein. Vielleicht müsst ihr einfach nur in Köln alle Taxifahrer fahren. Nee, es war nicht, ich sag nicht, wo es ist.
Okay, okay.
Weil ich habe echt Angst, dass es noch einen Backlash hat.
Ja, okay. Weil ich habe echt Angst, dass es noch einen Backlash hat. Ja, okay, gut. Weil es ist wirklich nicht gut, sollte man nicht tun. Stimmt, wenn man nicht weiß, wo das Verbrechen stattgefunden ist, kann man dich auch nicht anklagen, oder? Muss man nicht immer da vor das Gericht, wo die Straftat stattgefunden hat? Erstmal ist ja alles lustig in Taha-Comedy-Satire, von daher kann man ja gar nichts, weil das ja alles nicht stimmt und ausgedacht ist.
Ja, vielleicht nächste Folge Skype aus dem Gefängnis, wir haben dann so eine große Glasscheibe zwischen uns und so Telefone. Telefone, die haben auch diese Bieter, die sind ja im iPhone mittlerweile, weil ich habe die noch alle so mit so Schnurr-Telefonen im Kopf. Weiß ich gar nicht. Diese bietenden Leute, haben die iPhones? Nee, die haben tatsächlich also Apparellllos, die haben tatsächlich auch mit Kabeln und sind dann da und müssen dann, und vor allem, das Geile ist ja, dieser Telefonist ist ja so ein Mittler, der ist ja nicht der, der das Geld hat, der nicht die Entscheidung trifft. Das weiß ich nicht, wie gesagt, alle Telefonieren die Eltern. Ja, vor allem wenn du der Einzige bist, der tatsächlich anwesend ist, denkst du ja auch, nee, ich tue jetzt auch so, als würde ich mit mir selbst telefonieren und dann so, vor allem, der macht dann immer so so Gesten so, er überlegt noch und der Raum lacht so, ha ha ha, der überlegt noch und der ist ja so, ich will nichts falsch machen. Ja, das ist schon richtig. Man erkennt dann diese Leute daran, dass sie sich am meisten aufregen, wenn sie es nicht bekommen. Bei allen anderen Mittelmännern ist es ein bisschen egal, aber der eine ist dann so, scheissamt! Telefon auf den Boden schmeiß Alle so, oh, hast du wirklich telefoniert? Mit wem hast du telefoniert? Ja, gut, wenn ich immer so 350 verkauft und mir das Bild überreicht dann so huch, zack und dann geht es kaputt. Und es schreddert sich selbst. Und daran arbeiten sich dann Juraprofessoren dann wieder jahrelang ab, wo jetzt genau, in wessen Besitz war jetzt das Bild? Wer muss es, genau, wo muss es sein? Wir machen heute eine Jura-Folge und ich möchte nur kurz sagen, wir haben kein Interesse daran, dass uns irgendjemand schreibt, wie irgendwas Jura funktioniert. Wir öffnen die Mails gar nicht, es interessiert uns nicht. Irgendwas Jura funktioniert. Es interessiert uns nicht, was genau Jura eigentlich ist. Ach ja, ich war gestern bei der Premiere von Star Wars, die Rückkehr der Sky. Ich kann dich gar nicht anschauen. Ich habe Angst, dass du irgendwie durch deinen Blick schon verrätst, wie der Film ist oder so. Ich habe ihn noch nicht gesehen. Ich möchte darüber auch nichts sagen. Du hast so ein verschmitztes Lächeln. Ich weiß nicht, ob das gut oder schlecht ist. Ich war nur bei der Premiere da, wurde ich eingeladen von Disney, hat mich sehr gefreut. Dadurch war der Film aber auf Deutsch, was mich wahnsinnig genervt hat. Oh ja. Wusste ich vorher auch nicht. Und die ganzen Synchronsprecher waren dann auch da. Das heißt, du kannst dich die ganze Zeit brüllen, wie scheiße ist die Synchrofassung, so klingt doch nicht Kylo Ren. Und die saßen nicht weit von mir entfernt, ich habe den ganzen Tag gedacht, oh, so eine Scheiße, auf Deutsch gucken. Haben die alles mit angesprochen? Ja, haben live eingesprochen. Und haben sich nur noch verheddert und so und verdattelt und dann wusste man nicht mehr, wer wer ist jetzt und was passiert. Er war deutsch leider und es war halt so eine unangenehme Influencer-Veranstaltung. Also man wurde da halt eingeladen, jetzt im Nachhinein ist mir auch klar, warum ich eingeladen wurde, nicht weil ich großer Star Wars Fan bin, sondern weil man halt eine gewisse Reichweite hat und deswegen wollten die, dass man dann da hinkommt. Da waren doch die Lochis und so viele YouTuber mit bunten Haaren.
Man nickt sich zu.
Man nickt sich zu und die denken, wer ist der Mann?
Und dann wird man aber gezwungen, dass das Volk kann dann in ihre, das waren dann viele, die haben Karten gewonnen und so, die konnten dann in ihre Kinosäle unbehelligt und unbelästigt. Oh, tschüss. Hi, hi Philipp, du hast es wieder mal geschafft, in eine Aufnahme zu kommen. Und dann fand man sich halt wieder, als jemand dann eingeladen wurde, die konnten einfach in den Kinosaal gehen und ich musste dann über diesen, es war kein roter Teppich, aber so eine Fotografiemeile. Nichts ist schlimmer als unbekannt auf so einer Fotografiemeile zu sein. Das ist das Unerträglichste. Und man wünscht sich an solchen Tagen dann aber, dass man bekannter wäre einfach. Nicht aus einer Arroganze heraus, liebes Intro, sondern einfach weil es unangenehm ist, über diesen Teppich zu gehen. Vor allem sind die Lochis und alle sagen Roman Roman, Roman, Heiko, Heiko, Heiko, Roman hier und alle Fotografen schreien und man betritt dann selber den roten Teppich. Alle schweigen, gucken runter auf ihre Kamera und tun so, als müssten sie schon die Bilder sichten, die sie gerade gemacht haben und swipen dann so durch. Und man sagt so, ihr werdet ja nicht nach Bildern bezahlt, also abgerechnet, ihr könnt einfach umsonst Bilder machen, ihr habt alle grosse Speicherkarten in euren Apparellos, macht doch einfach kurz mal ein Foto von mir, zumindest damit ich mich gut fühle, ich könnte das nachher wieder löschen, ist mir egal, oder so, aber dann hatte ein Kollege von mir eine sehr gute Idee, man sollte einfach einen Fotografen positionieren, der dann sucht, ah, halt, hietze, wir brauchen ja nur einen, einen, der sagt, haltetze, dann denken alle anderen, okay, ah, den kennt man ja offensichtlich, ich kenne den nur nicht, und der muss dann ausrasten, dann würden alle mitmachen, das mache ich demnächst dann einfach, dann schläufe da jemanden ein, aber so war es dann sofort, ich stille und man geht einfach beschämt über diesen Teppich, weil es gab keinen Weg daran vorbei, ich wollte erst außenrum, ging dann nicht. Das Ähnliches habe ich erlebt, damals beim Comedypreis, beim ersten Comedypreis, und das Problem war, du bist so ein langer roter Teppich, und bei mir war die Situation, dass ich glaube, irgendwie jemand, vielleicht habe ich es in der Folge gesagt, oder sagen wir es mal, Annette Frier war vor mir, und die ist dann halt so langsam durch und hat halt bei jedem Polk Fotografen angeheilt und halt posiert, und ich war hinter ihr, das heißt, ich konnte nicht einfach weiterlaufen an ihr vorbei, sondern ich musste halt stehen bleiben. Und guckst halt dann mal in die Kamera. Ja, und halt dieses unerträgliche Erwarten, dieses Ignorieren, ich hätte sie natürlich nicht erwartet und so, aber es ist halt so unangenehm, weil man halt so rausfällt. Das ist so eine Anti-Laola-Welle, man ist es tief an einer Laola-Welle, immer wo man ist, nehmen die alle ihre Fotoapparaten runter und man denkt so, soll ich jetzt trotzdem posieren oder soll ich irgendwas machen? Es ist extrem unangenehm. Ja, und dann greift man dann so lustige Sachen wie man macht ein Selfie oder so. Ja, ja. Es ist so der Moment, wo man bekannt ist, dass Leute denken, man könnte das machen, aber noch nicht bekannt genug, dass die Fotografen das merken. Das ist dieses Limbo, was einfach furchtbar ist. Was in allen anderen Bereichen des Lebens toll ist. Ja, ich meine, du warst da, du durftest auf die Premiere.
Genau, wir geniessen viele Vorteile. Man kriegt Dinge umsonst schon jetzt angeboten und so einen Scheiss und kann zu tollen Veranstaltungen gehen oder nicht zu tollen Veranstaltungen gehen, aber man kriegt Dinge angeboten, das ist irgendwie cool. Manchmal erkennt man, erkennt einen Leute und dann wird das Ego gepusht und wow und es ist nicht so nervig, noch nicht. Und das ist total angenehm und gut, aber dann in anderen Bereichen des Lebens, wie bei solchen furchtbaren Veranstaltungen abends, denkt man sich, ach das ist genau die Art Bekanntheitsgrad, die man nicht will. Weil, na ja, das war sehr unangenehm, aber dann kam ich rein, musste mein Handy abgeben, kurz, nur um es dann direkt wiederzubekommen, in einer zugeklebten Silberfolie, wo ich dachte, was genau soll das jetzt helfen, weil ich kann es ja einfach wieder rausholen im Kino. Dann kam aber raus, es macht ein sehr lautes Geräusch und dann kommen sofort so Mitarbeiter von Disney und nehmen das ab, das fand ich nicht so unkle nicht so unklever. Aber wie muss man sich die Stimmung in so einer superpremieren Vorführung vorstellen? Also da sind ja viele Star Wars Fans, wie du auch gesagt hast. Nee, ich wäre lieber in dem anderen Saal gewesen, wo die ganzen Fans, die bei Gewinn spielen, sogar vier oder so, und nebenan waren halt die coolen Leute, die Fans, die das gewinnen wollten, sich da beworben haben und so. Und da war bestimmt mega Stimmung und so. Aber in diesem Influencer-Saal war einfach nur, vor mir sass jemand, neben mir sass auch ein Fan, der hat dann den vor mir gefragt, weil er war ihm schon ein bisschen älter, hat gesagt, ich habe damals den ersten Film im Kino gesehen. Und das ist für mich jetzt heute Abend total toll, dass ich den letzten Film im Kino sehe. Ah, krass. Und dann meinte der vor mir, der Influencer, meinte dann so, ja, wann war denn nochmal der erste Film? Irgendwann 98 oder so, ne? Den habe ich auch gesehen. Ich dachte, das kann auch nicht mehr ernst sein. Und das zog mich so ein bisschen durch den ganzen Saal, diese Distanz und so. Und ich habe mich wirklich, also bei vielen Stellen habe ich laut Reaktionen geäußert, kann man sich ja denken, es gibt ja bei jedem Star Wars, Star Wars ist ja voller Twists and Turns und, ne, ich will nicht so viel sagen, aber das ist ja normal bei Star Wars Filmen. Es gibt Lacher, es gibt Momente. Genau, er hat seine Momente, die halt sehr laut sind und weil irgendwas krasses passiert in irgendwelche Richtungen.
Und da reagiert man natürlich, war halt auch immer das einzige in diesem Saal. Und mich interessiert, ob da noch jemand war, der es gehört hat, weil ich habe ein paar Mal laut reagiert. Und ich bin mir sicher, in dem anderen Saal haben alle genauso reagiert. Das fand ich sehr interessant und sehr traurig, dass es auf deutsch war. Und jetzt gehst du selbst durch die Welt in so einer Plastikfolie. Du hast es gesehen, aber du darfst nichts sagen, du willst es niemandem spoilern, du kannst deine Meinung nicht ausdrücken, du kannst mit niemandem reden. Ja, ab morgen ja, da haben ja alle Star Wars Fans schon gesehen, schätze ich mal. Ja, ich weiß es gar nicht. Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe immer so ein bisschen Angst, bei den ganz frühen Screenings zu sein, weil dann ist immer so diese, guck, das habe ich dir doch gesagt, da haben wir doch im Forum darüber gesprochen, aber halt so diese unangenehmen Fans, die dann irgendwie alles kommentieren müssen und immer dann jetzt denken, weil sie so grosse Fans sind, können sie sich rausnehmen, dieses Erlebnis einzunehmen. Ich verstehe schon, ich habe keine Selbstdisziplin, aber und kann nicht so gut vor Spoilern fliehen im Internet und kann nicht gut weggucken.
Kann ich total verstehen.
Und deswegen gucke ich lieber früh, um dann unvorangene Reihen zu gehen. Weil wenn man einmal Reddit anklickt und die Stop-Reddit adoptiert, die ich adoptiert habe, dann kommt man nicht im Spoiler herum. Und das ist ein bisschen blöd. Und von daher bin ich froh, das jetzt schon gesehen zu haben. Ja, nee, kann ich verstehen. Reden wir nächste Woche in Ruhe drüber. Und natürlich auch in Antennazka.
Bei Antennazka werden wir auch über den Film reden, auf jeden Fall, selbstverständlich. Nee, schön. Wir können auch nochmal irgendwann Antennaaunland hinterher schieben. Ich bin ja gerade total im Herr der Ringe-Fieber, ich schaue mir gerade das ganze Bonusmaterial an. Ich habe schon angefangen, das ganze Bonusmaterial. Ich habe ja die grosse Extended Edition DVD-Box, wo pro Film vier DVDs drin, zwei für den Film, zwei für Bonusmaterial.
Die habe ich auch.
Jetzt habe ich alles digitalisiert, alles auf eine Festplatte gepackt, damit ich es schön im Zug anschauen kann und irgendwie unterwegs anschauen kann und hau jetzt das ganze Bonusmaterial rein, den ganzen Scheiss, die ganzen kleinen Sachen irgendwie, auch nicht nur die grossen Dokus, sondern auch so die kleinen, wo man dann über Minuten lang dann irgendwie die Landschaftsscouting-Aufnahmen findet und so. Es ist so grossartig, diese Leidenschaft, die in den Filmen geflossen ist. Und auch dieses Commitment der Produktionsfirma zu sagen, wir machen A3-Filme auf einmal, wir machen so viel Geld, so teuer, wir schmieden alle Waffen selber und die Location-Scouts. Und dann immer die Momente, wo Peter Jackson sagt, ja, wir haben da den perfekten Hügel für Edoras gefunden, aber der war weit weg und wir mussten da schon Strassen hinbauen. Also ich hatte so ein bisschen Angst, das New Line Cinema zu pitchen. Und denkst du dir, wie hat da jemals jemand Ja dazu gesagt, wenn Peter Jackson sagt, ja, für die Paar-Szenen im zweiten Teil müssen wir jetzt ein komplettes Versorgungssystem an diesen Hügel bauen. Und die haben gesagt, okay. Da kam alles zusammen. Also das war vor allem auch eine Zeit, wo das noch möglich war irgendwie. Aber selbst dafür war es ja irre. Also dann kam da noch hinzu, dass da Leute einfach in den Positionen saßen, die man gebraucht hat. Und glaube ich auch ein Regisseur, der genug Wahnsinn hatte, das auch dann fortzuschlagen und so weiter. Er bekam so viel zusammen. Auch Peter Jackson war ja damals kein berühmter Regisseur oder so.
Der hat ja so ein paar Horrorfilme gemacht.
Es war keiner, dem man mal blind einfach die paar hundert Millionen überlässt, aber super krass.
Und ich finde natürlich auch, wenn du sagst, hat alles zusammengepasst, auch die visuellen Effekte natürlich, die damals gut genug waren, um Sachen wie die Geisterarmee und Helms Klamm und so zu machen, aber nicht gut genug, um zu sagen, wir brauchen keine Modelle, wir brauchen keine Rüstungen und so. Wir brauchen das alles schon und wir brauchen noch die praktischen Effekte, aber wir können zumindest diese fantastischen Elemente alle umsetzen, anders als bei der Hobbit, wo alles im Greenscreen irgendwie teilweise so grüne Rüstungsteile haben, die dann im Postbuch machen. Da siehst du es ja, ne? Gleicher Regisseur, gleiches Source Material. Ja, nicht von Anfang an gleicher Regisseur, der wurde ja gewechselt dann. Ja, wirklich, bei Hobbit? Ja, ja, das war ja Jamo Del Toro. Ach was, wirklich? Ja. Ach so, und wann wurde er gewechselt, im Prozess? Ja, irgendwann relativ spät eigentlich erst, dann musste Peter Jackson anstellen. Das wusste er nicht. Ich dachte mir nur, halt am Ende des Tages dann gleiche Regisseur, gleiche Ressourcen-Material, gleiche Welt, gleiche Produktionsfirma, gleiche Drehorte zum großen Teil, aber furchtbare Filme. Das ist eine traurige Geschichte. Und vor allem bei Star Wars hatte man ja immer, dass jetzt, wenn nochmal eine neue Trilogie nochmal neu aufgemacht wird, so dass originale Trilogie brillant ist, die Prequel scheisse. Ich weiß nicht,
ob es Herr der Ringe noch mal so ein drittes Element geben
kann, dass man noch mal so, wie jetzt die
aktuelle Trilogie, noch mal so eine
neue Entwicklung hat. Gibt ja bald die Serie
für eine Milliarde Dollar. Das stimmt,
das stimmt. Obwohl man, finde ich, bei den Hobbit-Filmen
einfach sagen kann, die existieren nicht so.
Das ist wie das Holiday-Special.
Ja, bei Star Wars ist es so okay, das ist halt Anakin,
das sind halt die Figuren so, aber bei Hobbit irgendwie da, keine Ahnung, ich habe irgendwie bei Hobbit das Gefühl, sonst besser Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr hat die auch noch fast besser gemacht. Also so, das ist schon Wahnsinn, wie kreativ diese Filme sind. Ja, aber auch nicht hinweg. Ja, aber auch wie Badass irgendwie.
Es war wie George Lucas einfach alles, was er wollte, gemacht hat und sich nichts geshärt hat.
Das kann man ja nicht abstreiten, aber auch wenn man diese neuen Filme sieht, diese breiten, plattgewaschenen, also es ist so kreativ und edgy und ikonografisch, was er auch, ich habe dann bei der Star Wars Celebration in Chicago hat Doug Chang, der Art Director von Lucasfilm, einen langen Vortrag gehalten über die Prequels und die Welten, die er da erschaffen hat, auf Naboo und allein Naboo, wie viel eine Architektur zu entwickeln und diese ganzen Völker, die Gungens deren Architektur, diese kleinen gelben Pfeiter, die da rumfliegen, dann ist es ja irre, auch die Porträt, was da alles reingeflossen ist, allein in diese paar Szenen in diesen beiden Welten, ist ja unglaublich. Und das hat man ja fast danach nicht mehr so gesehen in der Fülle. Und du kannst ja so viele Sachen davon jetzt abrufen, wie die aussehen und nachmalen einfach. Das ist schon Wahnsinn. Naja, also ich bin sehr gespannt, vielleicht reden wir nächste Woche nochmal darüber. Aber vielleicht kommt 2020 eigentlich so ein richtig krasser Film, ein richtig krasses Franchise. Worauf kann man sich 2020 denn freuen? Ich weiß nicht, ich bin da immer nicht so drin, ich hänge da immer so ein bisschen hinterher, was das angeht. Aber es gibt bestimmt Sachen, ich bin mir nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, aber ich lebe grösstenteils in der Vergangenheit. Ich schaue mir noch Herr der Ringe an, ich schaue mir die Oceans-Trilogie an zu Weihnachten, ich bin komplett in der Vergangenheit drin. Es gibt so ein paar Filme, zu denen man immer wieder zurückkommt, ist aber auch gerade bei mir extrem irgendwie, weil ich bin immer überfordert, wenn ich auf Netflix klicke oder auf andere. Erstmal muss man sich für einen Streaming-Anbieter entscheiden, so was ist heute für ein Tag. Ich habe jeden Abend so eine andere Stimmung, also so eine Prime-Stimmung habe ich manchmal, so eine Netflix-Stimmung, immer unterschiedlich, so eine Apple-TV, gekaufte Serien-Stimmung und dann guckt man mal, wo man gerade Lust drauf hat und da war wieder ein ein Überangebot und dann macht man immer gar nichts oder liest ein Buch oder sowas. Am Ende klackert es eh runter zur YouTube-Stimmung. Zu YouTube. Unten der Bodensatz ist immer die YouTube-Stimmung. Wie spät ist es wieder, ist YouTube. Ja, genau. Unten ist immer auch dann irgendwie, es ist schon zu spät für Netflix. Aber auch auf YouTube komme ich wieder aufs Lächeln. Wir haben darüber mal gesprochen und hast du mir mal gezeigt, damals eine ganz tolle Video-Essay-Reihe über die Chaos-Theorie, illustriert mit Lego-Männchen. It's so blatant, heißt der Channel. Unglaublich toller Channel. Und das gucke ich mir auch jedes Jahr einmal an. Also da gibt es auch, auch da bei YouTube hat man ja, durch dieses Überangebot, glaube ich sowieso, rationalisiert mir das, kommt man immer wieder zu den gleichen Sachen zurück, wo man weiß, die gefallen mir. Ja, aber wir haben es schon oft gesagt, aber der YouTube-Algorithmus ist echt gnadenlos. Vor allem, ich habe eine Schwäche, ich weiß nicht warum, aber ich habe eine Schwäche für Golf-Videos. Und zwar, es gibt ein ganz spezielles Format an Golf-Videos, und zwar irgendein Golf-Verlag oder so lädt einen Golf-Profi ein, und die geben dem 500 Bälle, und der muss ein Hole-in-one schaffen. Und die Frage ist halt, schafft man es in 500 Bällen ein Hole in one? Und weil diese Golfprofis sind halt immer so total ruhig und cool und reich, die haben so eine Ausstrahlung, die sind irgendwie so Akademiker und Sportler. Die sind auch witzig und clever und irgendwie kosmopolitisch und irgendwie, die sind halt irgendwie in der ganzen Welt unterwegs und die drehen alle irgendwann durch, weil die nicht ein fucking hole in one hinkriegen. Und nach 200 Schlägen, nach ein paar Stunden, sagen die wirklich, das ist der schlimmste Tag meines Lebens, ihr habt noch nie so Geschlecht gespielt wie heute und die knicken alle ein irgendwie und das ist so interessant, diesen Arc zu sehen, wie die alle kaputt gehen. Aber was ein tolles Format. Ist ein brillantes Format. Aber man sollte es anwenden auf alle anderen Sportarten. Hey, Mathis. Ja, kannst du das fragen? Klar. Werbung. Weißt du, was ich heute gemacht habe? Ich habe heute sämtliche Weihnachtsgeschenke besorgt. Und es ist so ein schönes Gefühl, weil du musst dich um nichts mehr kümmern, du kannst dich einfach zurücklehnen und kannst Weihnachten so einfach auf dich zukommen lassen, egal was passiert, du bist raus. Das ist wirklich das beste Gefühl. Und vor allem kann man das ganz, ganz einfach machen. Denn wo hast du es getan? Natürlich bei Aldi. Naja, ich habe jetzt bei Aldi nicht meine Weihnachtsgeschenke gekauft, aber so was man halt sonst so drumrum braucht, so irgendwie dann den Lebkuchen ganz, so irgendwie die Gäste kommen, die Schwiegermutter kommt, so die Basics, die man halt so braucht, so den klassischen Weihnachtseinkauf, kannst du alles bei Aldi machen, kannst du auch gleich mehr kaufen, weil die Preise sind immer tief, Qualität ist immer gut, das Zeug hält sich bis 2080. Und Aldi gibt's an jeder verkackten Ecke, das muss man auch immer sagen, in jeder Drecksstadt, ihr könnt noch wo wohnen, da gibt's ein Aldi, ihr könnt nicht vor Aldi fliehen, das ist auch ein Vorteil, denn Weihnachten ist man im Stress, man will nicht mehr ewig fahren. Wenn ihr irgendwo in der Pampa seid, seid sicher, da gibt es zumindest ein Aldi. Wenn man lange genug geradeaus fährt, endet man irgendwann im Frischbackregal von Aldi, wo alles frisch gebacken wird, wo ich alles frisch mitnehmen könnte. Ich wollte nicht wenig bezahlen, ich wollte gar nichts bezahlen, verstehe ich auch. Dann geht doch einfach mal, klickt euch mal durch beim Aldi-Vents-Kalender, denn da könnt ihr jeden Tag tolle Sachen gewinnen, die rund um Weihnachten euch das Fest noch ein bisschen schöner machen. Und wir wünschen euch ein fantastisches, schönes Weihnachtsfest mit Aldi. Werbung. Ja, hier war ein harter Cut, war hier gerade zu hören, weil einfach Leute in dieses, ich nenne es mal Büro, kommen, um uns zu konsultieren. Nee, aber diese Golfvideos schaue ich immer ganz gerne an, 500 Bälle, ein Hole in one. Und der YouTube-Algorithmus checkt nicht, dass ich nur an dieser ganz expliziten Art von Golfvideo interessiert bin. Und gibt mir halt alle möglichen Golf Open und Tiger Woods und alles. Und ich so, nein, hör auf jetzt, hör auf Google.
Ich will dem so auf die Schnauze hauen, nein. Bei mir ist, was ich total gerne mag, eine ganz spezielle Art von Videos, wie Prominente ihre Ten Essential Things vorstellen bei GQ. Es ist von GQ und jetzt denkt der Algorithmus aber, ah, das ist ein GQ-Fan. Also kriegt Health, Lifestyle, Videos, so viel Mode, Uhrenkram jetzt auch in meinen Teilen gespült, weil der nicht checkt, dass ich nur an dieser Art Prominente erzähle, was sie benutzen tagtäglich. Es müsste für den YouTube-Algorithmus so einen Button geben, so ich will dieses Video jetzt anschauen, aber bitte denkt ihr da jetzt nichts dabei. Ja genau, das hat nichts mit meinen Interessen zu tun. Genau, ich schaue das für einen Freund. Ja, ich habe einen schwachen Moment, sowas. Ja genau, so der SW-Modus ist ein schwacher Moment, bitte verurteile mich. Ich will, wenn ich morgen aufwache, nichts mehr davon wissen. Lass uns nicht mehr darüber reden. Du könntest der Button auch halten. Lass uns nicht mehr darüber reden. Ja genau, ich möchte nicht, dass es auftaucht in meinen zukünftigen. Weil ich will nicht den Cognitive-Modus aufmachen, weil das wird sich dann wieder schmutzig anfühlen. Ja, ja genau. Dann gucke ich andere Videos an, auch aus Gewohnheit. Ja, habe ich jetzt tatsächlich auch entdeckt, wo wir gerade bei YouTube sind, es gibt eine relativ grosse Szene auf Pornhub, die keine Pornos sind, sondern YouTuber, die Content machen, der nicht mehr auf YouTube zugelassen ist, machen ihn auf Pornhub. Wie zum Beispiel hier meine Lieblingspornos. Kannst du natürlich nicht auf YouTube zeigen, weil du zeigst ja Pornos irgendwie. Aber die machen dann aber wirklich ein ganz normales YouTube-Video, so meine Top-10-Pornos, aber auf Pornhub oder irgendwie so Reaction-Videos zu Pornos oder so. Halt irgendwie schauen sie sich ein Porno an und dann irgendwie keine Ahnung, was gefällt einem oder nicht. Das ist eine ganze Zeit, ich bin davor noch nie drauf gestossen und habe mich da mal so durchgeklickt, auch von so Leuten, die halt so Content machen einfach zu Pornos auf Pornhub, was halt auf YouTube... Wie findet man das auf Pornhub? Naja, du musst halt dann so ein paar Leute wissen. Also Open Mind kann ich hier empfehlen, der macht ja auf dem YouTube-Kanal zum Drogen und so. Und der macht ja auch so Drogen-Selbsttests und so. Und ich glaube, ab einem gewissen Punkt sagt YouTube, nee, lass mal. Aber ab einem gewissen Punkt sagt Pornhub, das hat nichts mit Pornos zu tun. Also diese umgekehrte... Das stimmt schon, da musst du so auf Drughub oder sowas. Ich glaube, Pornhub ist relativ egal Die haben da relativ wenig Richtlinien. Aber das wird doch der Trend sein, dass Dinge, die irgendwo gesperrt werden, auch aus anderen Gründen. Wahrscheinlich. Und es gibt auch oft dann tatsächlich auch so aus der rechtsextremen Ecke oder so, dass da Videos, die da gesperrt werden, sind auf Pornhub. Das heißt, du hast auf Pornhub, ich glaube, da gehen die dann schon gegen Sachen vor. Ich glaube, die haben dann irgendwie so eine eigene Kolik. Aber wer ist das dann? Ist das eine Firma? Wer Pornhub hat? Ja. Ich glaube, bei Pornhub kannst du ja erstmal alles hochladen, was du willst. Aber wer sichtet diese Sachen? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es wirklich nicht. Aber ich glaube, die haben einfach andere Richtlinien als YouTube. Und das ist dann, wenn du da mal in der Gegend bist, bist du in einer ganz merkwürdigen Subökonomie. Ich habe auch bei Pornhub nur das Gefühl, ich habe das Gefühl immer, da müsste mal jemand eine Seite machen. Pornhub macht es ja schon, auch mit Merch und diesen Statistiken, die sie immer rausgeben, die gut designt sind und so. Du hast bei Pornhub nicht mehr das Gefühl, was Schmutziges zu machen. Also natürlich noch, aber du hast nicht das Gefühl, was Illegales zu machen und so. Wenn man sich diese Videos da teilweise anguckt, das geht doch nicht mit rechten Dingen zu, würde ein älteres Semester jetzt sagen. Bei welchen Videos meinst du jetzt? Ja, da sind doch manchmal schon weirde Videos dabei, wo man sagt, das ist jetzt in der Umkleide gefilmt oder whatever, oder das ist doch jetzt gegen den Willen. Es stimmt schon, aber das Problem ist halt, wie will man das überprüfen? Also auch teilweise so mit Alter und so. Jetzt wird es keine Ahnung, niemand weiß, ob die 17 ist oder so, weil du wirst ja nicht anrufen bei irgendwie keine Ahnung, Pornolord 65 und dann sagen, Entschuldigung, können Sie mir die Geburtsurkunde von Ihrem Model bitte schicken.
Weil im Grunde im Endeffekt, wenn es niemand irgendwie flaggt oder meldet oder so, wird es natürlich da bleiben, ausser es natürlich offensichtlich Kinderpornografie oder so, dann natürlich schon. Ich habe das Gefühl, aber der Umgang mit Pornoseiten und so ist meiner Meinung nach in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung ein transparenterer und weitaus reflektierterer Umgang mittlerweile. Und deswegen kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es irgendwann eine Art Netflix gibt für Pornos, für das viele bereit wären, auch Geld auszugeben. Oder so ein Abosystem, vielleicht gibt es das schon. Also ich weiß, ehrlich gesagt, weil tatsächlich... Pornapremium mässig. Ich stelle mir wirklich manchmal die Frage, wenn ich so auf Pornhub unterwegs bin, so, wann kommt der Punkt, wo ich für Pornos Geld ausgeben würde, weil ich konsumiere mein Leben lang Pornos, aber habe noch keinen einzigen Cent ausgegeben, noch nie, und ich denke mir so, es muss ja, es muss ja irgendwo der Punkt kommen, weil die müssen ja Geld verdienen, das ist ja eine riesige Infrastruktur, es gibt ja Leute, die das machen, sind die so anders als ich eigentlich? Also ich würde dafür Geld ausgeben, wenn es halt eine, wenn ich weiß, es ist ein Konzern, der gibt sich Mühe, dass da alle über 18 sind, alles ist Konsent, alle sind dabei, wissen, dass sie gefilmt werden und so weiter. Und dann, weil das habe ich bei Pornhub nicht das Gefühl, obwohl die ganze Seite und das Merch und so alles einem das sagt, ja, ja, wir sind eine richtige Firma, das läuft schon alles hier, habe ich das Gefühl, nee, das glaube ich noch nicht. Und ich glaube, ich wäre bereit und ich glaube viele andere auch, Geld auszugeben, wenn man dann eine Seite hat, die da wirklich hinter steht. Ich frag mich, wann der Punkt kommt, aber vielleicht kommt es irgendwann noch, weil es gibt viele Dinge, bei denen ich nie dachte, dass ich jemals Geld dafür ausgebe, aber dann irgendwann doch einfach angefangen habe. Jeder hatte ja mal so eine Phase, wo man einfach sämtliche Filme illegal geschaut hat, einfach alle. Und irgendwann denkt man sich halt, ja, ist halt schon scheiße oder so. Und jetzt über iTunes US oder so gebe ich teilweise recht viel Geld aus für einzelne Filme. Ja, ich auch. Aber wenn man halt anfängt zu arbeiten und sich überlegt, dafür kann man auch Geld ausgeben und so.
Ja, und du hast dann einfach auf der Festplatte irgendwie, du kannst es runterladen, es ist da irgendwie, du hast dann vielleicht noch Bonusmaterial, Kapitel, es ist irgendwie alle Fahnen. Und gute Qualität, ist auch schön. Aber vielleicht ist es bei Pornos auch irgendwann so, dass da auch so ein Bewusstseinswechsel stattfindet und man einfach selbstverständlich einen Teil seines Geldes für Pornos ausgibt. Ja, genau, ja, es gehört ja ein Stück weit auch zum Leben in der digitalen Welt so dazu.
Und deswegen muss man, glaube ich, da mal, ich fände es immer gut, wenn man da irgendwie, wenn man da jemanden in die Welt eindringen würde, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, und dann immer eine schöne, eine schöne Seite programmiert. Ja, deswegen fand ich es toll zu sehen, dass es da auch YouTuber gibt, die eben, oder Content-Creator, die auf Pornhub dann eben auch Content machen, wie ich empfehle euch meine Lieblings-Pornoseiten und so. Und stöbert da mal durch, man findet da verrückte Dinge auf jeden Fall. Ja, auf jeden Fall findet man viel. Das ist schon irre, was man da auf Pornhub. Vielleicht müssen wir diese Folge auch auf Pornhub hochladen. Pornhub-Podcasts. Ja, stimmt, das ist gar keine schlechte Idee. Gibt es da eine gute Erotik-Podcasts? Es gibt so Erotik-ASMR auf jeden Fall. Aber ich weiß nicht genau, ob es... Naja gut, es gibt natürlich viele Sex-Podcasts, aber jetzt wirklich so als pornografische Sex... Also das wären dann eher so Romane oder so Erotik, gelesene Erotik-Geschichten oder so. Die gibt es ja auch. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wo man die finden kann. Also so Schmuddel-Romane eingelesene. Ja genau, eingelesene Schmuddel-Romane. Aber das will man auch nicht hören. Vor allem ist es ja dann schwierig, wo fängt man an, wo hört man auf, wo fängt man dann beim nächsten Mal wieder neu an, wann ist die Story zu zählen, wo man sagt, jetzt komm, auf geht's. Ja. Ja, erste SMS, Eis, Vanille-Eis, Schoko, ja, gut, Pinocchio-Becher, komm, ja, ich hab's verstanden, ihr mögt euch, und weiter, weiter geht's. Bitte, und los, und los, zack, zack, zack, zack, soll ich nicht nach Hause fahren, mein Uber ist, ja, und weiter, komm, nein, ist es an den Platten, muss er ranfahren, ADAC, erst mal ADAC, ich bin nicht beim ADAC, ah, okay, ADAC. Die ADAC-Frau, ah, okay, aha, komisch. Nee, sie schlägt den nur ab. Sie müssen mal den Vergaser anschauen. Welche Seriennummer hat die denn? Acht, fünfundfünfzig und skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, skipp, sk Gott, oh Gott. Ach ja, Porn ist auch nicht mehr das, was sie mir waren.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall spannend. Da glaube ich, aber muss was passieren.
Ich glaube auch.
Da müssen wir mal, lass uns mal Leute anrufen.
Kennst du jemanden, das muss doch eine große Firma sein, ist das ja auch eine deutsche Firma, Pornhub eigentlich?
Dachte ich immer, oder? YouPorn?
Ich weiß nicht.
Einen Deutschen ist so ganz vorne mit dabei, der hat diese ganzen Sachen mit an den Start gebracht und ist, glaube ich, mittlerweile auch irgendwie so ein Selfmade-Millionär. Weiß ich nicht genau, bin ich hundertprozentig sehr. Anderes Thema, Weihnachten. Ich habe ein kleines Weihnachtsgeschenk für dich. Nein, doch. Nein. Was denn für ein... Ich glaube, aber du hast es schon. Ja? Ja. Willkommen. Ich glaube, du hast es dir schon selber gekauft, aber es ist mir über den Weg gelaufen. Und ich wusste nicht hundertprozentig, ob du es hast oder nicht. Deswegen habe ich es gekauft, weil ich dachte, wenn du es nicht brauchst, nehme ich es selber. Aber ich glaube, du hast es schon. Ich bin so aufgeregt. Hier ist mein Weihnachtsgeschenk für dich. Ich habe es nicht eingepackt. Das ist nicht so schlimm. Eingepackt ist auch überschätzt. Ich bin so aufgeregt. Bitte schön. Oh mein Gott, das ist total cool. Das habe ich noch nicht. Wie cool ist das denn? Sehr gut. Das ist ein mega Geschenk. Freut mich. Vielen Dank. Ja, gerne. Du hast mir von Reklam, wir hatten schon länger bei den Sachbüchern gesprochen, die in der pinken Farbe erhältlich sind und du hast mir das zum Thema Dinosaurier geschenkt. Genau, weil du Dinosaurier hast. Von David Norman. Ich bin ein großer Dinosan und du hast mir das Reklamsachbuch geschenkt. Das kannst du schön über die Feiertage ein bisschen lesen, ein bisschen was über Dinosaurier lernen. Also, Dinosaurier faszinieren und David Norman gelingt es, diesen Giganten auf kleinstem Raum gerecht zu werden. Wann wurden sie zuerst entdeckt? Wie wurden die Funde interpretiert? Welches Verwandtschaftsverhältnis besteht zu den Vögeln? Sehr konkrete Frage dann plötzlich.
Wie verlässlich oder realistisch sind Rekonstruktionen?
Warum hat der Triceratops beim rechten Horn ein bisschen länger?
Bisschen ein bisschen längeres Horn, ein bisschen gedreht, also eingereht nach rechts.
Wie wird heute auf diesem Gebiet geforscht? Und nicht zuletzt, was für Lehren können wir selbst als Spezies Mensch aus dem verschwindenden Niesaurier ziehen?
Hinten raus wird es nochmal ein bisschen gruselig. Schön, nochmal ein bisschen abhocken.
Ah, das freut mich total. Megageil, vielen Dank. Niesaurerziem. Hinten raus wird es noch mal ein bisschen gruselig. Schön, noch mal ein bisschen apokalisch. Das freut mich total.
Mega geil, vielen Dank. Lies rein, hab Spaß. Jetzt habe ich ein sehr vieles Gewissen, weil ich dir kein Geschenk. Nee, kein Problem. Ich dachte nur, ich habe ein bisschen, weil ich habe selber ein paar Bücher bestellt zu Weihnachten und so. Da dachte ich mir, weil der wurde mir vorgeschlagen, dachte ich mir, komm, nehme ich für den Stefan mit. Mega. Mir ist jetzt neulich, ich hatte Quantentheorie, hatte ich schon. aber da ist mir jetzt ein bisschen ironisch eine Banane in meinem Rucksack geplatzt und die war so ein bisschen alt und ist halt über Quantentheorie ergossen. Und jetzt ist Quantentheorie, es wird halt so dunkel, komischerweise Banane, wenn es halt eintrocknet und alt wird irgendwann. Und dann war es so, ist nicht mehr so schön leuchten pink, sondern so ein zermodertes bananiges Schwarz. Und in der U-Bahn hat man das, man liest es ja auch in der U-Bahn, um ein bisschen was herzumachen. So um jemand auszusehen, oh, der liest Quantentheorie, der muss es drauf haben. Das ist bestimmt ein sehr schlauer, gut sortierter Mensch, aber es ist leider ergötzt sich halt diese Bananen, er giesst sich so jetzt darüber. Von daher freut mich, dass ich ein neues Buch habe. Ich hatte das Sachbuch Gehirn, habe ich leider verloren. Ah ja, vergessen muss es. Erinnerungen habe ich, glaube ich. Es gibt ja auch. Ich habe leider, ich habe auch das Quantentheorie, habe ich auch gelesen und ich dachte, habe es letztens noch mal in meinem Buchregal gesehen und dachte mir, was weiß ich eigentlich noch? Du hast es komplett gelesen. Ich habe es komplett gelesen, ich setze mich mal hin, ich überlege mal wirklich, was weiß ich noch davon? Keine Ahnung. Fast nichts. Klar, so ein paar Sachen, Halbwahrheiten, so ja, irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, kleinsten Teilchen, die haben so viele Zustände und in einem Ort sind die so und wenn man das am anderen Ort ändert, dann ist es da auch und wenn man das misst, dann wird dann erst festgelegt, was es ist und so, aber so genau weiß ich es auch nicht. Ich habe das Gefühl, aber das Gehirn weiss ziemlich genau, was es sich merken sollte im Leben und was nicht. Ja, und das Gehirn weiss es zu gut. Ja, aber warum kann mir das das Gehirn nicht einfach mal mitteilen? Weil ich habe Interesse an Quantenphysik, lese es, aber mein Gehirn sagt, das ist mir eh nicht. Nee, mehr nicht. Da rein, da raus. Schaut euch den Trottel an, der liest das Zeile für Zeile, nichts davon wird hier aufgeschrieben, schmeißt das alles raus direkt, schmeißt das raus direkt. Aber ich glaube, wir sind da sehr ähnlich, ich habe ein grauenvolles Gedächtnis und deswegen komme ich auch mal zu den gleichen Filmen, weil Herr der Ringe amaisst mich jedes Mal aufs Neue. Oder jetzt habe ich mir, wie gesagt, wieder diese Chaos-Theorie-Reihe angeguckt und ich wusste nichts mehr. Es hat mich genauso mitgerissen und gepackt wie im letzten Mal. Und da dachte ich mir, geil, so ein schlechtes Gedächtnis ist vielleicht auch ganz gut. Ja, es ist ärgerlich, weil die Dinge, die einen interessieren, sind nicht die Dinge, in denen man gut ist, oft. So, ich interessiere mich für ein Thema, aber merke so, erstens, es liegt mir nicht, zweitens, ich merke es mir nicht, aber es interessiert mich trotzdem noch. So, man müsste das irgendwie so ein bisschen besser synchronisieren. Vielleicht gibt es da irgendwann so einen Threshold, durch den man so, dann ist man drin. Es gibt ja auch dieses Phänomen, dass je mehr man über ein Thema weist, desto mehr fühlt man sich dumm in dem Thema. Ja, das ist nochmal, das ist halt ein Name. So ein bisschen das Gegenteil vom Dunning-Kruger-Effekt. Ja, ja. Oder der Dunning-Kruger-Effekt, so dass man sich für inkompetenter hält, je mehr man über ein Thema weist. Und das kann natürlich auch ein Teil dieses Effekts sein, dass du das Buch liest und am Ende denkst, ich habe keine Ahnung von Quantenphysik, aber nur weil du jetzt das Thema umrissen hast in seiner Gänze und davor hattest du vielleicht so ein paar Grundideen und dachtest, das reicht schon, kann auch sein. Oder man vergisst einfach alles komplett. Ja, ich vergiss sehr viel. Das interessiert mich sehr. Ich frag dich ab über Dinosaurier. Im neuen Jahr frage ich dich ab. Was ist jetzt die Verbindung zu Vögeln, warum werden die immer falsch dargestellt?
Tatsächlich ein interessanter Post, den ich auch gesehen habe, auf Nine-Gag war. Ja, frage ich dich ab. Was ist jetzt die Verbindung zu Vögeln, warum werden die immer falsch dargestellt?
Tatsächlich ein interessanter Post, den ich auch gesehen habe, auf Nine-Gag war, dass jemand geschrieben hat, ja, Dinosaurier werden oft völlig entfedert dargestellt, gerupft dargestellt und würde man einen Schwan so darstellen, sähe er so aus. Der sah aus wie ein Dinosaurier. Der Schwan ohne Federn sieht aus wie ein Dinosaurier, weil du hast diesen langen Hals und dann halt diese Klauen, weil Flügel ohne Federn sehen halt aus wie so Klauen halt einfach. Und das sah halt aus wie so ein, sah schon anders aus als ein Dinosaurier, aber so im Grundkonzept denkt man sich schon, ja, das sieht aus wie ein Dinosaurier, wo man dann wieder rückwirkend denkt, dann müssen wahrscheinlich die meisten Dinosaurier schon so ausgesehen haben wie Vögel einfach. Wie Riesenvögel. Ja, wie riesige fucking Vögel. Ich hätte, da gab es irgendwann mal so Raumfahrer, so Rick and Morty-mäßig, Adventure Time, ist man durchs All geflogen und ist damals mal auf der Dinosaurier Erde gelandet und hat einen Planeten mit Riesenvögeln gesehen und ist schnell rückwärts zurückgeflogen. Das ist nicht unser Planet, draußen. Und schnell wieder so, what the fuck is happening here, ist zurückgeflogen, wir sind noch nicht, dieser Planet ist noch nicht breit. Ja, weil ist es, werden Dinosaurier nicht auch einfach kalt, also wenn die sind ja ganz nackig. Ja, muckelig, aber es war ja auch viel, aber ich verbinde Dinosaurier auch immer mit Vulkanen, komischerweise ist das direkt daneben, also in meinem Kopf leben Dinosaurier immer, du meinst, dass die wie um so ein Lagerfeuer, um so ein Vulkan rumstehen, so ...
Ja, die leben in meinem Kopf.
Oh, Alter, ist ein bisschen kalt, oder? Das liegt aber auch immer, ich weiß nicht genau warum, ich glaube, weil auf den Covern der Bücher mit Dinosaurier immer schon der Untergang mit angeteast wird. Als wir das erste Mal in New York waren, waren wir in so einem Thrift-Shop und da habe ich so ein altes Poster gekauft, wo auch so Dinosaurier abgebildet sind. Da waren Dinosaurier und im Hintergrund ein Vulkan und ein Blitz schlägt gerade ein.
Ja.
Wo man das Gefühl hat, wo auch so Dinosaurier abgebildet sind, und da waren Dinosaurier und im Hintergrund ein Vulkan und ein Blitz
schlägt gerade ein. Wo man das Gefühl
hat, das ist so weit von der
biologischen Betrachtung empfiehlt.
Einfach sämtliche
Naturgewalten, nur weil es Dinosaurier
sind, einfach wenn du ein Pferd malst,
machst du doch auch nicht einen Blitzeinschlag
und einen Vulkanausbruch im Hintergrund.
Aber Dinosaurier sind ja einfach so
badass, die muss man auch so darstellen. Ich glaube, weil man auf Covern, die ich kenne, so was ist was, da geht es halt auch irgendwann um den Untergang Dinosaurier. Und deswegen glaube ich tiest man das mit an in dem Buch. Ach so, damit man am Ende nicht zu geschockt ist. Ja, und auch weil das Teil der Geschichte davon ist. Am Ende geht es halt um Vulkanismus und Meteoriten und so. Deswegen glaube ich, landet es dann irgendwie mit auf dem Cover, so wie ja auch Darth Vader mit auf dem Cover landet, weil er mal drin vorkommt bei Episode 5. Ich glaube, an irgendeinem Punkt wird es dann alles anwiesen, was in dem Buch vorkommt. In meinem Kopf ist immer, leben die in einem Urwald und im Hintergrund sind Vulkane überall. Und deswegen ist die muckelig warm, glaube ich. Ich glaube auch, dass wenn Dinosaurier nicht ausgestorben wären, sie vollkommen uninteressant wären. Die würden heute durch die Gegend laufen wie Giraffen. Ich glaube, wir würden auf Raptoren, die ja nett gezüchtet sind wie Pferde ja auch, auf netten Raptoren würden die Polizisten reiten. Warum willst du denn auf einem Raptoren reiten? Auf Pfauen reitet auch niemand. Nee, aber auf Vogelstraussen zum Beispiel. Auf Pfauen nicht, das macht ja keinen Sinn. Auf Straussen? Auf Vogelstraussen kann man reiten. Manche Leute reiten auf Vogelstraussen. Bin mir nicht sicher, ob das immer der Plural ist, aber ich glaube... Naja, okay. Ich glaube, das Einzige sind Flugsaurier, weil ich glaube, Flugsaurier waren die grössten flugfähigen Tiere. Oh mein Gott. Sobald man auf denen reiten könnte, dann hat es halt gewonnen, dann hat du halt Leben durchgespielt. Aber niemand reitet auf Kondoren. Ja, aber Kondore sind doch kleiner. Hat man jemandem ein Baby auf einen Kondor gesetzt? Hat das noch jemand gemacht? Es gibt bestimmt ein YouTube-Video, hundertprozentig Baby on Kondor. Hat man jemandem ein Baby auf einen Kondor geschnallt? Das ist meine erste Frage für Quora. Kennst du Quora? Nee. Habe ich ein Konto, kann man Fragen stellen? Baby auf Kondor. Das ist keine Frage. Kondor ist leider auch die Fluggesellschaft. Und schon verloren, schon einfach Geld umsonst. Schließlich kriegt man ein Foto, wie ein Kondor eine Sonnenbrille hat, auch nicht schlecht. Aber gibt es ein Tier, auf das noch nicht eine Sonnenbrille gesetzt wurde? Das ist die eigentliche Frage, die wir stellen wollen. Ich glaube, jedes Tier hatte schon mal eine Sonnenbrille auf und ein Ha-Ha-Foto gemacht, Klick. Und dann so, warum nehmen sie wieder weg? Alle Tiere sind auch enttäuscht, weil sie dann keine Sonnenbrille behalten durften. Schnecke mit Sonnenbrille. Wo wir auch bei YouTube sehen, eines der abgefahrensten Genres an Videos ist für mich dieses farbenblinder Mensch kriegt Brille geschenkt, die die Farben sehen lässt. Du schaust mich völlig ratlos an, hast du noch nie so ein Video gesehen? Nein. Irgendwie so, wir haben zusammengelegt. Doch, doch, erster Taubermensch kriegt dieses Koch hier. Ja, aber das gibt es eben auch für Farben. Unser Opa ist irgendwie farbenblind und dem schenken wir eine so eine Brille. Und dann hat er diese Brille auf und dann dreht er komplett durch und fängt an zu heulen, von wegen so klar hat er die Welt noch nie gesehen. Ein abstruses Video, weil man auch immer so denkt, so wie geht es jetzt weiter, so lebt er jetzt ab jetzt die ganze Zeit mit dieser Brille? Sieht ihr albern aus? Stellt ihr nicht einmal die Frage, warum nicht letztes Jahr, hallo, ein Jahr lang habt ihr mich hier rumlaufen lassen ohne Farbe?
Warum filmt ihr mich dabei?
Warum hat er sich die auch nicht selber gekauft? Weil jeder farbenblinde Mensch muss doch mittlerweile auch so ein Video gesehen haben. Und dann so, ich habe ja nächste Woche Geburtstag, ne? Da hat er dieses virale Video hier gesehen von, die schenken ihrem Opa zum Geburtstag so eine Brille, wo man Farben sehen kann. Guckt ihr mal an, das ist total rührend, oder? Aber ist das eine alberne Brille, die so bunte Elton John hat? Also die sieht nicht so mega cool aus, was halt das Problem ist so ein bisschen. Aber kann man das nicht als Kontaktkennende auch bekommen? Oh, das glaube ich nicht, weiß ich gar nicht. Ich keine Ahnung, was in dieser Brille passiert. Vor allem, warum sowas so leicht zu lösen ist mit einer Brille. Warum kann man nicht einem Blinden einfach eine Brille geben und dann kann er wieder sehen. Irgendwie auch bei Augen lasern lassen, warum nicht eigentlich? Also es ist so gut erforscht und machbar mittlerweile, kostet halt sehr viel Geld. Aber da kann man ja mal was sparen, das ist ja schon ein sinnvoller Eingriff. So eine Brille aufzuhaben, nervt schon auch immer. Ja, ich wollte ja mal jemanden, der sich die Augen lasern lassen wollte, wollte ich das ja mal schenken.
Der meinte immer so, ja, ich habe kein Geld dafür und ich würde das so gern machen, weil ich hasse Kontaktlinsen und so. Dann dachte mir, komm, wir legen alle zusammen, schenken dem das. Es ist aber recht teuer. Also das ist wirklich teuer. Also nur ein Auge. Oder halt in Ungarn. Weil in Ungarn kostet das halt so, keine Ahnung,
1500 pro Auge, ist zwar immer
noch fucking teuer, aber wenn der ganze
Freundeskreis vielleicht zusammen liegt, aber
dann ist ja die Frage, kann man jemandem
nichts gegen Ungarn,
aber kann man jemandem guten Gewissens
eine Augenlaser-OP
in Ungarn schenken, weil derjenige denkt sich A, danke, B. Man könnte es verpacken in so einer netten Ungarnreise. Ja genau, so wird das ja auch gemacht, so ein Wochenende Budapest. Ich habe ja bei dieser Callcenter gearbeitet, wo auch so Zahnreisen verkauft wurden, Budapest-Zahnreisen. Oh mein Gott, hochgradig. Ich weiß nicht, ob es shady ist oder ob einfach, keine Ahnung, deutsche Ärzte überdurchschnittlich viel verlangen wegen irgendwas, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung. Aber der erste Impuls ist erstmal Danke, aber... Nein, nein, danke ist der erste Impuls. Und vor allem, was macht man dann? Dann sagt er, dann nehme ich es. Aber du hast doch schon perfekte Augen. Ja, aber vielleicht klingt die noch ein bisschen besser. Vielleicht klingt die noch ein bisschen besser, oder? Rauskitzeln noch. So Minusdioptrien, so. oder plus. Man kann jetzt in die Vergangenheit gucken vielleicht. Also durch die Wand gucken. Wo ist das Limit einfach? Wo ist das Limit? Where is the Limit? Ich weiß es. Ja, weil viele haben ja 120 Prozent. Ich glaube, viele, mit denen man spricht, haben 120 Prozent, weswegen ich ja immer diese Skala in Frage stellen muss. Ja, warum? Weil die ist doch Menschen gemacht. Warum geht mehr als 100 überhaupt? Oder kann niemand Prozentrechnung der Augentests macht. Ja, oder die Augen waren früher schlechter und man dachte sich, holy crap, das geht ja immer besser. Ja, ja, das glaube ich aber nicht. Wir haben ja auch so Shrimp, es gibt so Shrimp, die können unendlich viel mehr Farben sehen und wahrnehmen als wir. Wir haben ja drei von diesen Farbdingern, deswegen werden ja Farben beim Digitalen immer in drei Ziffern angegeben, weil wir drei von diesen Dingern haben. Und es gibt so einen Shrimp, der hat vierundzwanzig davon. Das ist unvorstellbar. Warum auch der das? Ach so, vielleicht um Feinde zu erkennen. Oder einfach, weil die Evolution sagt, wie, vierundzwanzig? Zwei haben wir gesagt. Hast du vierundzwanzig aufgeschrieben? Ja, vierundzwanzig. Ach, Scheiße. Es gibt auch Menschen, die haben vier. Es gibt manche Menschen, die haben vier. Ach, und die sehen das Kleid dann goldbraun. Ja, das weiß ich gar nicht, aber die sind schwer zu finden. Was ist aus dem Rätsel eigentlich geworden? Was ist das Internet gespaltet? Wenn wir jetzt bei Farben anfangen, Farben ist ein faszinierendes Thema, weil natürlich nicht jeder dieselben Dinge mit denselben Worten beschreibt und so, klar kennt jeder, aber auch so wie du Farben wahrnimmst. Es gibt zum Beispiel irgendeinen, ich glaube es ist irgendeinen Optiker oder so einen Typ, der das erforscht hat, der hat seinem Kind nie gesagt, dass der Himmel blau ist. Also der wusste, was blau ist, aber er hat nie erwähnt, dass der Himmel blau ist, wurde einfach nie gesagt, wurde einfach nie in Bezug genommen, dass der Himmel blau ist. Und dann hat er sein Kind gefragt, welche Farbe hat eigentlich der Himmel? Und das Kind so weiß, konnte es nicht so richtig beschreiben. Ich weiß nicht genau, was es gesagt hat, vielleicht hat es eine andere Farbe gesagt. Aber irgendwie ist es ganz merkwürdig, dass wenn du mit Konzepten noch nicht in Berührung gekommen bist, dass du es dann auch anders siehst. Das ist ganz merkwürdig. Wo wir da ein bisschen bei unserem indogenen Volk ist, was Jaws anders, früherregender wahrnimmt als Schubert. Oder dem man den New Yorker Straßenverkehr gezeigt haben und dem gefragt wurden, was sehen sie, und die haben gesagt, Hühner. Wir sehen Hühner, durch die ihn laufen, obwohl sie Autos gesehen haben, aber da sie das nicht wahrnehmen konnten, haben sie auch keine Autos gesehen. Vielleicht alles gefakt, vielleicht alles falsch. Bitte schreibt keine Mails. Bitte schreibt keine Mails. Schreibt mal lieber eine Weihnachtskarte. Schreibt es lieber in die Kommentare, dann können es die anderen auch lesen, dann werden wir alle klüger und nicht nur immer Stefan. Weil sonst wird immer nur Stefan so super klug. Ja, wir werden, nee, wir beide, wir kriegen immer diese ganzen Belehrungen, teilen die nicht mit, weil wir es auch vergessen. Ja, natürlich. Wir werden immer cleverer und cleverer und irgendwann verlieren wir den Boden. Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare, dann haben alle was davon. Dann müssen wir dich nicht so aufpumpen wie so ein Wissensballon und am Ende platzt du. Genau, so machen wir es. 2020 wird dein Jahr? Das können wir in der nächsten Folge nochmal ausführlich besprechen. Stimmt. Da machen wir nämlich die große Jahresrückblick und Jahresvorausblick. Warum nicht mal Vorausblick, das macht man nie. Wir machen nächste Woche mal ein Sowjet 2020 für uns. Und so stellen wir uns das vor. Machen wir mal eine große Orakelshow, was wir glauben, was nächste Jahr passiert. Du hast vorhin letztes Jahr mal gesagt, dieses Jahr werden Joko und Klaas keine grosse Rolle spielen. Ja. Hattest damit die erste Jahreshälfte auch sehr viel Erfolg. Nee, aber es stimmt. Ich habe völlig recht, weil Joko und Klaas spielen keine Rolle. Doch, aber dann haben sie diese tolle Aktion gemacht, wo sie 15 Minuten pro sieben Sendezeit bekommen haben und tolle Leute zu Wort haben kommen lassen, grimme Preis, jetzt überall Jürgen und Klaas, Gewinner des Jahres etc.
Also du hast so halbrecht gehabt und dann grandios versagt, das kriegen wir nächstes Jahr besser hin.
Ich glaube, wir orakeln mal ein bisschen rum, das Orakel von Pufo und dann wird man ein bisschen werden man vor Sachen
in unseren Händen gelesen, mit unseren
Haaren.
Haut rein, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche, vielen Dank nochmal an das
Intro und
lieben Gruss an euch alle, geniesst die Weihnachtszeit,
kommt mal ein bisschen runter, geniesst es.
Schöne Weihnachten und lasst euch reich beschenken.
An MC Schmid, haut rein, macht's gut, bis dann.
Ciao und wir heben ab
mit einem weihnachtlichen